- I couldn't begin this journey
without two women who have
been a part of my heart
for over 20 years.
We are friends, we are fellow Angels.
Please welcome my partners
in crime and life,
Lucy Liu and Cameron Diaz.
(audience cheers)
(women shrieking)
(Cameron laughs)
Oh my God, you guys!
This is the loudest this room has been!
(women laughing)
Oh my God, you guys.
It's hard to keep it together, man.
I just felt like bursting into tears.
I'm just so happy we're all together.
- The three of us.
I haven't seen you guys,
well, all three of us together
in a very long time.
- We all made "Charlie's Angels."
We made it and we're making this show.
And so when we sat around
and thought about who is this first guest,
nothing felt right, nothing was there,
and all of the sudden,
in a divine intervention,
I was like,
"Cameron and Lucy," and
everything fell into place.
- Massive congratulations,
this is really major for you.
- Listen, everybody says, "Who's
gonna be your first guest?"
I mean, we've been through
everything together.
- Well, everything, literally.
- Everything!
- Literally every thing.
(Cameron and Lucy laugh)
- I haven't had a wedding that you guys
haven't been at.
(Lucy laughs)
- [Cameron] I've been
to all your weddings.
- Exactly.
- I've been to all of them.
- When our babies are born,
we hang out and we do
the birthday party thing.
I can't believe we're all moms now.
That's when I got really emotional.
First, I sent Cameron a video
and I'm saying, "Hey, listen,
I wanna ask you something.
Will you come on the show?"
I've never done this in my life.
Because I'm so comfortable,
I mean, we have lived
together all over the world,
so of course, to save time,
I sent her a video while
I'm getting dressed.
(Cameron and Lucy laughing)
And you don't see anything.
I'm not that dumb, but I'm
getting out of the shower
and I'm wringing out of my towel.
And I don't hear back
from her for two days,
and I'm like, "This is weird.
"Did I, what is going on?"
So I text her and I'm like, "I don't care
"about the question, are you okay?"
I don't hear again for two
days and I'm freaking out.
So I call her and I'm
like, "What is going on?
"I'm worried, is everything okay?"
She's like, "I don't know
what you're talking about."
I'm like, "The video,
you didn't get my video?"
Turns out, a young boy got the video.
(audience laughs)
- Lucky him!
- [Drew] Oh, no.
- Oh, no, by the way,
it's seven minutes long.
- Oh my God!
(women laughing)
- It's epic, I mean,
this is some material.
- So many secrets revealed.
- This kid's gonna have this material.
Honestly, this is gonna last
him three or four years.
(women laugh)
- I'm really hamming it up because it's--
- 'Cause it's you?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it was good.
I was like, "Send me
that video immediately.
"I need to know what is in that video,"
and the whole while, I'm just cracking up
because it's just--
- You need to send me
this video, as well, or do
it through someone else,
because I didn't get
your other video, either.
- So then--
- Someone said,
- I sent--
- "Did you get her video?"
I was like, "No."
- No, something's wrong with my phone.
So I sent Lucy this video, crying,
inviting her on the show,
saying--
- In her bathroom, crying.
- I am in my bathroom.
- She was dressed.
(Cameron and Lucy laugh)
- I was fully clothed
this time, I didn't take the risk,
and she didn't get the video, either!
(Lucy laughs)
- Come on.
- I know, I know.
The thing that I love about our friendship
is that we have been there
in all the big and important moments.
We've also been there in the small moments
and the casual moments.
And the reason we are such good
friends is because it's real
and we go through real
stuff with each other.
It's not a Hollywood fairytale.
- There's no aspect of life
that's an actual (laughs)
Hollywood fairytale.
That's why it's a Hollywood fairytale,
'cause it doesn't exist.
It's aspirational, it's hopeful,
but life is constantly
full of twists and turns
and all of those things
that happen over a lifetime,
because truly, it is now a lifetime.
I mean, 20 years is a long time, y'all.
I'm two years away from 50.
(laughs) That's nearly half my life.
We have "Charlie's Angels" as our backdrop
that brought us together,
but then we get to fill in
all of life together in real moments,
which I just so appreciate
so much.
- It's so true.
That's so well said, honey.
- I know.
- Because it's
our touchpoint.
- Yeah.
But then we have that foundation,
and then we've obviously
grown and learned and changed.
And I mean, I know that
20 years has gone by,
but I feel like it was yesterday.
I feel just as fresh and
as young and as creatively,
I don't know, excited
as I was when I started.
- Here's the thing about
"Charlie's Angels,"
is that it's about girls
who can do all of these things
and love each other and
don't have competition
and support each other and laugh
and wanna talk about love and life so much
that they actually start
to talk about love and life
while they're fighting,
because women are so like that.
It all intersects.
(Cameron and Lucy laugh)
And that is why I asked
you guys here today
is because if you're
gonna do something big,
you wanna do it with your girlfriends.
- That's right.
(audience cheers)
- And I love being together,
although are we really together?
Are we all together in this room?
- Are we, I feel like we're connected
in some way, but maybe--
- For anyone watching,
can you guess which one
of us isn't really here?
(Lucy gasps)
(Lucy exhales)
(Cameron and Lucy laugh)
- Welcome back!
- I'm the one in Los Angeles.
(everyone laughs)
You gotta try this, it's so incredible.
The ether does little
particles going out into space
and coming back and reamassing
into this beautiful space.
You guys, it's crazy, you
should try it, it tingles!
(everyone laughs)
- And if you guys wanna know
how that awesome,
groundbreaking technology works,
just go to our website at
thedrewbarrymoreshow.com.
(upbeat music)